any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
a legendary figure in my life in physics
in cosmology and philosophy in
mathematics and that is
professor lee smolin joining us from the
perimeter institute
our neighbor to the north lis mullen how
are you today my friend
i'm very well thank you and thank you
very much for the kind words and
the invitation lee you've made uh
fundamental contributions in many
different aspects
of cosmology of physics philosophy um
but what i first want to turn to is the
influence that you had
on me as a younger physicist as a
beginning professor back in 2006
when uh your really apocal book called
the trouble with physics came out
this book influenced me and a whole
generation of physicists both
theoreticians and experimentalists like
myself
and there are very few books that in
physics that are relevant 14
15 16 four years three years two years
after they're written let alone 15 years
after
and in this book which i reread
re-listen to recently in preparation for
this interview
i noted that you were talking about the
stagnation in physics in the previous 25
years
so if i add i'm not as good at math as
you are but if i add 25
to 15 i get 40. yes wow i just do
do you still stand by that or do you
still observe that same stagnation uh to
some extent
in in physics at least in theoretical
physics obviously experimental physics
is
completely different there are certainly
areas which are doing very well
there are areas of quantum materials
where the theory is really
interesting and i love thinking about it
um i think it's still true that
we have not made a fundamental discovery
experimentally that we explained
theoretically or theoretically posited
something
that was discovered experimentally
and i we still don't know the
why questions about the standard model
why those
they're now something like 3d parameters
including
the now that the neutrino has mass
including the masses and mixing angles
of the neutrino
and we have no explanation for what the
values of those
dimensions constants are nor for the
strength of the gravitational
constant nor for the dark energy or the
cosmological constantly translated is
and i went into physics to
understand why why the universe was the
way it is
and there's lots about that we can get
if we can get into the universe
is is not it's not just some random set
of numbers out there the universe
is enormously structured and
organized and self-organized and that
seems
to be at least partly due to those
constants being in certain narrow
windows
where there are lots of chemical and
nuclear reactions
that can take place so i
i think i stand by that
we don't have uh we have ideas about
quantum gravity and we have more ideas
than we did 15 years ago
none of them have some of them to make
experimental predictions
but none of those predictions have
enough to help
you always be default like as you would
know we've looked for the rents symmetry
breaking
at the kong scale and around the
prophecy are using astrophysical
experiments and the evidence is that
it's not there
and there's a number of other anomalies
that we look for
and they're not there so um i
i it's a very frustrating period when we
look at
alternatives to string theory which has
become and still remains
a dominant paradigm i've had
conversations with
uh with carlo rovelli who's become a
dear friend and
actually we are collaborating together
and he is another person i thank you for
putting me
in touch with many years ago and we are
collaborating on the first ever
audiobook
version of galileo galilei's dialogue on
two chief world systems
the first physicist yeah it's going to
be amazing with
another italian physicist along with jim
gates reading a forward
from galileo fabiola giannate another
stay tuned for more information about
that you can get more if you subscribe
to my newsletter at briankeating.com
uh but i want to uh turn our attention
to
some surprising developments that i had
talking with a string theory
proponent and that was michio kaku who
came on my podcast recently in promotion
of his new book
the god equation which he claims you
know string theory is responsible for a
series of successes not stagnations
even even such things like the g minus
two anomaly
and the uh and the lhc uh beauty
experiment anomaly
that these things are hints tantalizing
hints of the efficacy
of string theory and i push back lee you
know i'm only a simple experimentalist i
said but
i said to my knowledge and you lee can
correct me if i'm wrong
nobody looked at string theory and said
let's predict
this uh correction to the uh to the g
minus two
uh from string theory and he pushed back
on me and said well nobody did that from
loop quantum gravity
because loop condom gravity is so
simplistic
it doesn't even have fermions in it and
i said
but because i'm just a fool
i don't i don't know how to answer him
you know and then we say in judaism know
how to answer a heretic
so i didn't know how to answer him how
would you have answered him michio kaku
when he says
loop quantum gravity which you are one
of its foremost exponents along with
abbas
uh abe ashtakar and karlo and others
but lee how should i have answered him
i'm sorry i let you down but how should
i have answered them no the way to end
there first of all loop carnal gravity
is a method it's not in my understanding
of theory
it's a method of
studying systems whose forces are
described
by gauge fields and we can talk about
what that means
like the standard model of general
relativity and that method
applied to general relativity yields
some very interesting
descriptions of what the geometry of the
world might be
on very small scales that is 10 to the
minus 30 something of a centimeter
um that method can be applied to
theories with fermions and there are
then the
fermions behave like fermions
so there's no problem including phones
there's no problem
coupling to gauge fields and coupling to
the
scalar in the front end of the standard
model
there is a very interesting issue around
chirality
which i know is a is an issue in
cosmology and astronomy that you've
worked on a lot and talked about so we
have uh
some issues about chirality which i'm
happy to admit
my feeling uh
and i i hope i can say this without
sounding egotistical or something
um i the
people you mentioned abi and carlo and i
are thought of often as the founders of
lukewarm gravity the inventives
um but let's break this break if it's
interesting
let's break that down um yeah
abide brought into being
an approach to general relativity based
on
seeing the geometry of space and time
life engaged here you know i can tell
you what that means
but it means we care more about
measuring
how things like fingers
or spins move around when you move
around
space that's called the connection the
connection tells
things how to move and
um my first role
i guess i had many but my first role was
that there was a whole bunch of
beautiful ideas and technology
theoretical technology that had been
developed
about qcd
mainly by a russian school sasha
gribaugh mcdowell
and there were also some americans
principally
ken wilson and they had a beautiful
picture
in which well do you know or do your
listeners know that if you pass magnetic
field to a superconductor
it becomes discrete there's a unit
of magnetic flux that
that flux line will take on
in this columnization and their
hypothesis
going what was also due to hogan nielsen
and a number of other people
was that in qcd which is sort of like a
complicated version
of electromagnetism with three photons
the electric field flux would be
quantized and discrete
and the there was a picture of strings
made out of that flux
holding forks together and i
basically stole that i mean it's
legitimate that's what we do in science
all that picture and technology and said
what if instead of qcd i plug in the
binds
theory about seeing gravity as a
and use all those beautiful ideas and
tools that
probably call him ken listen and that
was
that was i got lucky in some sense
because i where and when i went to
graduate school who was immersed in that
those ideas and those technologies and i
was the first
to try to apply them to quant to quantum
gravity
and i had a picture in my head of
groups and areas being quantized and so
forth
and that picture with a lot of
input from other people became plant
gravity
and particularly carlos brought
a very important picture of how to
think of the quantum mechanics of all
that
but now but now it's
that was the middle 80s i don't want to
count that's a long time
i love blue planet gravity it's been a
family it's been an adventure of friends
but it has problems too
and i'm happy to talk about them i'm not
i would not think of myself
as a proponent in the sense of somebody
who ignores the issues
i think there are issues and
when i set up a research center at
perimeter
i used a philosophy which is part of the
book you want to talk about the trouble
with physics
which i gained from the philosopher paul
fyrabin
which was to get good people from
diverse points of view
and don't privilege one point of view
just because i have a legacy
with that theory get good people who do
who think of quantum gravity from
several points of view
and have it and have the conflict
which is what the trouble with physics
was about
right so there are people in the
loophole gravity world
who think that i abandoned them and
there are people in the rest of the
world who think that i'm a lupun gravity
guy
and i'm neither
uh i i really love the way you say that
and you know when i think about things i
i often wonder you know are we
are we putting the gut before the toe or
the toe before the gut
and and by that i mean you know we don't
have a
good grand unified theory yet in my
opinion or my understanding
and yet people want to look for a theory
of everything first of all i think a
theory of everything and i think michio
does a disservice to be honest by saying
that this one-inch-long
god equation will describe everything
it'll give you soup and nuts and it'll
give you aliens
it'll give you avatars traveling at the
speed of light cruising around the
galaxy
it will give be you know and and it will
win you a nobel prize that einstein
couldn't win and you know how i feel
about the nobel prize as hey geographic
um you know kind of idol worship
onanistic idol worship
uh nevertheless it's it's important uh
to consider
what is the importance of a theory of
everything
and i wanna ask you are we putting the
the toe before the gut
should we in your opinion spend more
time thinking about how do we unify the
theories that you know we have
very strong evidence to believe that are
unified i personally don't believe
that we should demand that gravity uh be
unified with quantum mechanics i hope we
can get into that
but uh what do you think should we focus
first on guts before we get to toes
well long before that
let's let's open up can we open up to
the whole universe
yeah it's it seems to me there are
two kinds of phenomena there
loosely speaking there are phenomena
i mean we believe you and i and most of
our company
believe some version of the the laws are
pretty stable and there are fundamental
laws and we're trying to find out what
they are and they're pretty stable
i actually probably disagree with you or
at least with most of our colleagues
i think those laws are changeable and i
think they do change
and i think they have changed and i
think that
because that's the only way we're going
to explain
the question of why they have a form
that they have
so i'm on the lookout for principles
by which the laws can change that is i'm
no longer
hopeful that there's going to be some
magic formula
that's going to tell us what the values
of all those problems are
i think it evolves that way because
there are consequences
for the physic for the natural world for
the physical world
with which we can come to thinking about
it that way
you have to invoke functional
explanation
a functional explanation is an
explanation of something
where you use some consequence of what
it does in the world
so there are
twenty to the thousand different kinds
of proteins roughly
that's 20 different amino acids in a
thousand places
is a typical protein that's a whole lot
more
than the kinds of proteins that exist
on the biosphere that are coded for in
the dna of the rna of the various
creatures
which are like a million so
any protein that exists is lucky
because most of the other alternative
proteins
don't exist and why did it get lucky it
got lucky
because for example my code for
hemoglobin
which is a fundamental way to move
oxygen around
within a creature and which
there's a lot of along with various
variants and
so forth so that's so if you ask why
does hemoglobin exist
sure it's got to you've got to be able
to analyze and see the laws of
electromagnetism
and so forth acting inside that crazy
wound up folded up thing but it's also
there's
also functional explanations and both of
them
have got to work so
i don't so i and i think that's going to
apply to everything
and i also don't take the mathematics
as dogma as religion if i can use that
i was at one time but i am no longer
looking
for that mathematical object which has
all the truth of that nature
to somehow um transcend our
existence and give our lives meaning
i think we do life meaning through
friendship and families and
what we believe in and who we love
and the universe kind of just
is doing the same thing so i
so i'm not many of our colleagues
are looking for something transcendent
when they want to know what the law is
what the standard my you know what the
true unified theory is
i would love to see some explanation of
the structure of the standard model
i've been attending a con we have weird
conferences of course as you know some
conferences are every week or somewhere
every month
so there's a conference about an idea
that used to get you kicked out of the
art
archive but it turns out to be solid
enough that there are a lot of
interesting
people doing it which is that that the
standard model has something to do with
the number system of actonians
and that would be cool um but i
certainly like some explanation where
does the su 3 cross sets you two come
from
where does the three generations come
from we all want
some kind of answer to that and my i'm
willing
i'm in fact either to have a functional
kind of example
for example this might come up later
if you want the universe to reproduce
itself through black holes which is an
idea that i had
you want the upper mass limit of neutron
stars
to be as low as possible so that as many
supernovas
lead to black holes as opposed to
neutron stars
and from that you can get a prediction
that the
heaviest stable neutron star can't be
more than two solar masses
and there's and the reason is some
complicated thing about the strange
quark i won't bore you with
unless you really really want but the
thing is that
recently there's better and better
evidence that there are some neutron
stars
up in 20 i'm sorry two solar masses 2.2
and so forth and if those hold up
then my my theory or my hypothesis
is falsifying and
and i and i will proudly say so
yeah you talk about that a lot in the
book you talk about you know
different gamma-ray burst signatures
that could be falsified as of
2006 uh you have other tests that could
be
you describe them as very exciting uh
variation
in the fine structure constant you point
out as very exciting and i've
i know that you have extreme you know
integrity
in all ways not only personally but
because you've you know because i know
you personally
but also because publicly you've talked
about how this has gone away
that there's no you've stated that you
kind of abandoned that
that hope and and you admit that it was
a hope back in the
uh early part of the uh of the you know
of the 2000s
that these fine structure constant could
be revelatory of new physics
but now it's ruled out and you accept
that and you move on
i i wonder you know when i first started
hearing about you from my
uh from my best friend stefan you know
i i always thought that you know when i
first learned about you
it was like what stephen hawking
reputedly said about
yaakov zeldovich uh when he met him he
thought that
zeldovich was like burbachi like a
collective
uh a a set of people and i i thought
that about smolin i thought smallin was
like satoshi
nakamura or whoever that guy is who
supposedly or collective came up with
bitcoin or blockchain
um i want to ask you you put out three
or four papers recently uh
and some of them with stefan some of
them solo uh papers
uh this voluminous effort i think you're
writing a paper right now i'd like to
see your hands lead could you put your
hands up so i i know that you're not
typing out a paper
as we're having this lovely interview
but i want to ask you
what would a theory of everything look
like uh would it be the semi-classical
wheeler dewitt equation that would be
fundamental would it be the schrodinger
equation
if gravity is is fundamental some say
the the schrodinger equation
if it's if gravity is emergent some say
it's the latter your recent paper is so
fascinating you have one called the
quantum mechanics
of the present written with clea verde i
think
yeah and the other one the symbiotic
emergence of
space and the quantum that one is a solo
paper let's talk about that firstly
please
what does it mean that for space to
become emergent what does that even mean
what it means is that the
organization that of space of things
moving in space is not fundamental it's
real
for sure of course we see it
but it's not fundamental and what i mean
is that
i'm looking like many of our colleagues
for a formulation of
a theory that is a story about the world
and how it's made
that will explain the mysteries of
quantum mechanics so i'm a little
ambitious
for better or worse explain the
mysteries of quantum mechanics and
resolve those issues like the
measurement problem
i want that same structure
to explain general relativity so to be
the quantum theory of gravity although
the fundamental theory that it's coming
from
is neither quantum mechanics nor gravity
and after a lot of
thinking and talking here i've been
influenced by
a number of people and it's always
important i mean we never do these
things alone so flotini marco poulo
was the first person who said to me
space
space does not exist so time can space
is
not in the fundamental list of things
that are
there all the way down but time is for
example space-time
is in some fundamental way a different
thing than matter
and if space-time is an emergent concept
then it's not really clear what you
would mean by unification
surely it would not be the unification
of matter with gravity
it might be a way to get gravity out of
matter that would be a different sort of
i guess you could think of it as a
unification scenario but it's a bit
different than what people are
considering now
and roberto montgomery hunger who's a
brazilian
philosopher was interested in the same
kind of things and
we wrote it was hard
but we wrote a very interesting book
together
that that book is called the singular
universe and the basic
idea of that theory that theory is now
called
the causal theory of views and the basic
idea of that theory
comes from leibniz the philosopher
and it's that and it's going to sound a
little weird
it's that the universe is composed of
partial views of itself so what i mean
is
that at every event and this is a theory
of events
and the causes between events there
might be two events here which in some
sense are the cause
of the third event which is the cause of
the fourth event
and each event has a past
has the things that led up to causing it
and i call that the view that's borrowed
from liveness
and um and i take
the set of all the views from all the
events
in the universe to be what the universe
is
and then i apply laws to those
and the main idea
there came from work in common with
julian barber
a long time ago which is to measure the
complexity
of some complex system whether it's a
city or an economy
or a piece of quantum space and time
by making the views from different
events or different
situations and it be as diverse as
possible
and you can write down a numerical
measure of that
and that we take as the
quantity that gets extremized
to give you the equations of motion
physics is often organized in such a way
that physics and
that gets extremized or minimized that's
called the
action and um
and so the theory has an action which is
related
to the what we call withdrawing the
variety
now the one last thing i have to say
about how this goes together
is that if you don't have space you
don't have distances between things
you don't have functions you don't have
fields you don't have derivatives
so how are you going to write down
dynamics all the
things that we'll go into are writing
down some law of a field or a particle
involve distances or derivatives or
fields
and so we don't have any of that but we
can do
is compare the groups we can ask you
look around where you are
i look around where i am and that
there's a mathematical language to
record that view and then they can be
compared
and so the whole dynamics that i develop
is based on those comparisons
so that's that's the basic idea then
what happens
in that paper um with unfortunately too
many tech
um technicalities and so forth is i
derive quantum mechanics from that from
those ideas
interesting now you mentioned julian
barbour he's an upcoming guest
on the into the impossible podcast and i
asked him
to ask a question of you and then i
and he responded and then i will ask you
to ask him a question uh that i will
convey
through me to him so his question to you
if you're willing to play this damn
game of time traveling questions this is
a
very uh inefficient way to use the
internet lee
uh i hope you appreciate how in time
inefficient this is to talk about time
in this way but anyway
lee julian asks you with what warm
regards he sends to you
if time is fundamentally what is it like
what are its attributes
very good so what we say
and this is in the work we did with
marina cortez
developing a prior
structure to the fear i was just
swimming what we say
is that the
business of time so i'm not going to
define i'm going to duck it
i'm going to say that the business or
the work of time
is to continually make new events
which make up so what i want to say what
time is life
is what we experience that is we
experience
the momentary present and the passage
of those moments when new things happen
and new things happen
and that's the business and the
mechanism of time
to keep choosing what new things get
made
and what they and therefore that chooses
what their past look like
i talked to frank wilczak about time and
and his basic
thesis you know is that you know time
and and entropy are somehow
fundamentally linked
uh carlo feels this way as well that uh
clausius equation of you know delta s is
greater than or equal to zero
entropy is yeah and that things change
and that frank then supplements that
equation
with the fact that a clock measures
something that is changing
and uh time is what we call the change
in something
so it's sort of a tautology but it's
almost the best that we can do so clocks
measure
time and time is what measure you know
clocks measure changing time
and uh and time is what clocks measure
and so uh and so but you know to to my
opinion
there because the you know microscopic
physics is
is is reversible except at the moment of
quantum measurement
it may be just like with the twin
paradox and you know i have twins and i
get to do experiments on twins all the
time
something i share with a lot of
physicist david kaiser uh sabine
hossenfelder
peter diamandez we all have twins some
of us have boy girl twins and that makes
it even more fun
uh but but anyway um you know the kind
of the
classic twin paradox uh which which you
talk about
in in your book on einstein and
unfinished revolution at some level
the the question is uh you know if two
twins set out one sets out at close to
the speed of light
turns around after a rocket voyage and
comes back uh to earth the other twin
gets
uh you know seems to have aged a lot on
earth even though
they seem to be moving at relativistic
speeds each one
experiences the other one moving
relativistically but it's the one that
undergoes the acceleration
when he or she turns back and comes back
so at that moment
that instantaneous moment it's almost as
if all the acceleration of time
takes place and i wonder is that not
possible
on the micro scale in other words yes
the microscopic laws of physics are
immutable they're time irreversible
until you do a measurement
and then that measurement that's where
all the time you know directionality of
time takes place
here's how i've been thinking about it
lately
and which which is um some of which
comes from
that last book uh einstein's unfinished
revolution
and some of it is recent work with
another collaborator who's clearly of
their day
and um and it was basically her idea
so she came to me and she said
so i start i think i worry about
the distinction between the past the
present and the
future and so
um my friend carlo and lots of people
believe that there is no objective
distinction between the past present and
the future
and i do i think that the time
is now now is real and
um and that that
matters to stating the laws of physics
and the question certainly the present
is real
but is the past is the future and how
does this relate to quantum mechanics so
clearly his idea
which turned out when we looked into it
to
to have quite a legacy which i'll come
to
is that the future
realm is indefinite
and everything that from quantum physics
is indefinite that is in part of a
superposition
critical this way could go this way is
part of the future
that is the wave function the quantum
state is a description of the future
and what the present is is the
resolution
of indefinite myths and ambiguities
to definitenesses because the past
is always only definite and
i think what is really interested in
that and shook up by that and then i
started to ask some friends and it turns
out that heisenberg
said this quite precisely it's not
it's hard to find but heisenberg said
this in schrodinger
and freeman dyson quiet at length and
one quote you can find
which of course we put in the paper um
so that's
and this is a new idea so it could be
wrong but
i'm kind of i find it very interesting
this idea
that um that
what the present is is the resolution
of indefinitenesses and ambiguities
and so let's play let's think about that
more
yeah i wonder if you know some of the
most interesting things in physics come
about because of anomalies
and those anomalies are really the
things that make you
sit up and notice as you know i'm a
pilot and you know an anomaly in the
cockpit is a is a flashing red light you
know and
and you ignore that at your peril and i
think you know those are some of the
greatest gifts that physicists have and
and one of the greatest gifts that we
got was in the 1950s
we noticed the parody and chirality of
nature
was not a perfectly obeyed symmetry
but we do think you know correct me if
i'm wrong that that the combination of
discrete symmetries charge parity and
time reversal
is respected but i wonder uh this is
work you did with joe amageo
uh and uh and others on on chiral
gravitational waves uh in 2008
that had some you know startling
predictions but i remember one line in
particular that stefan really
drove home to me was that you make the
claim that if the laws of physics are
unified
and if the electro weak sector you know
violates
parity as we know it does uh then if
gravity becomes unified with the electro
weak sector then it's almost unavoidable
that gravity will have some chirality
and i guess this is characterized by
this emuritsy parameter etc
can you say more has your thinking on
that evolve that was one of the most you
know kind of
uh you know earth-shattering bombshells
that i ever heard because
it meant that in my field we might see
bigger chiral anomalies in the cosmic
microwave
background that might illuminate physics
beyond the standard model
indicative of lorentz invariance
violation which is more startling to me
than inflation
yeah me too um
i i think i i don't know if i have
anything new to say i'm very
grateful for your interest in other
observers
who who has taken these things seriously
enough to really look for them
and um um but
let me here's here's something which
is which fascinates me uh
generality and i'm not assuming
that our listeners your listeners are
experts in physics but general
relativity
has a reputation of being difficult
partly because the einstein equation is
really complicated
and it's a function of this thing the
metric that measures distances
but you've got the inverse of the metric
and the determinant of the metric and
the square root of the metric
and the determinant of the metric
and it's it's a mess to compete with
and it's sure a mess to make quantum
mechanical
so what a bai used turned out
we didn't he didn't know that we didn't
know that at the time
but a polish
physicist who was a refugee to mexico
named plebansky had discovered something
wonderful
which is that you can look at the
einstein equations
in from a kind of different point of
view which is
chiral that is where you only focus
on how the left-handed neutrinos
are react to a gravitational wave
and that director and the neutrinos and
if you do that
you get equations which are just
quadratic equations
periods there's no determinants there's
no square roots there's no inverses it's
just quadratic equations
and if something were simpler than that
it would be linear and then
linear or linear equations we can solve
so it's as simple as it can get while
still
being non-trivial and loop quantum
gravity
the reason why all those ideas worked
is because our body rediscovered
poganski's
formulation so now so that makes me
wonder
um does nature know about this
and right so for example roger penrose's
great construction i mean he's done so
many great things but the greatest in my
opinion is twister theory
it just found a lot of use in particle
physics and string theory and
quantum gravity but of its own is a very
radical
idea and twister theory has this
chirality
built into it the left-handed
gravitational waves are described in a
way that's different than the
right-handed
gravitational wave interesting so that
it was an earlier yes and you do speak
about that
in the book and also roger's been a
guest four times on the show
as well and his 90th birthday is coming
up and i'm delighted to be asked to
speak
on behalf of that uh of that wonderful
okay
and uh that'll be something to celebrate
in uh in august i believe
is his 90th birthday it's quite amazing
and and thinking about his late great
colleague
stephen hawking who uh passed away three
years ago it's hard to believe
uh and this this notion that you know he
kind of died without having
unified you know quantum mechanics with
gravity i've been having this
provocative
statement lee and at the risk of
insulting my mentor
you know lee smolin and friend um i
don't know
that gravity has to be unified with with
quantum mechanics i mean after all
there are only two situations to my
knowledge at which the quantization of
gravity
uh the failure of gravity to play nice
with quantum mechanics
becomes important and that's near a
singularity in a black hole
and near the origin of the universe if
indeed it began with a singularity which
sir roger as you know does not believe
it did and paul steinhardt does not
believe it did and many others do not
believe
it did neil turock your colleague does
not believe it did
um and so there's one very questionable
scenario that could get ticked off that
we don't have to worry about quantum
gravity in that scenario
and a black holes uh you know what's
beyond below the event horizon as you
know better than almost anybody else
uh we we cannot observe the uh the
details you know what happens in
in the singularity inside the event
horizon stays inside the event horizon
so why do we care i mean would there be
any signature of quantum
gravity outside the event horizon and
that would be the only or are there
other scenarios in addition to physics
beyond the
event horizon that is relevant to the
uh the mandate that we must quantize
gravity
very good so i'm going to give you
another reason
i mean i'm very interested in the idea
of quantum gravity
and i don't think there's an open and
shut case that we shouldn't quantify
but here's something i've been
fascinated by since graduate school days
um and in i'll tell the background
in graduate school days um i got
interested in einstein i was always
interested in science
and i had a friend who was a historian
of physics emilia michelle cohn
and she made the proposal to me she said
why don't we
read all of einstein's papers
from the beginning at least the first 10
years or so
and very few of them were in english
except the three or four classics
why don't we start with his very first
paper which was on
thermodynamics in life and read
with her translating and read forward
and so we did that and
there was a thing that was very apparent
as we did that which is that he was
enormously interested
in the consequences of applying
thermodynamic ideas to life
and therefore he was very interested
in the situation which is called the
ultraviolet catastrophe
where if you make a box with conductors
and you must you must actually know how
to do this
and you put some light you have a little
hole
and you put some light in and you close
the hole the light bounces around
it doesn't interact with itself as it
interacts with the walls where the
conductors are
and it thermalizes itself it bounces and
bounces and bounces
and bounces and thermalizes itself and
then you open a little hole and you put
a spectrograph there
and it comes out the black body spectrum
and that was really interesting for
einstein
because the black body spectrum without
even
having the form of the spectrum although
he did actually of course this was after
planck so he knew planck's guess and it
was
obvious that classical physics couldn't
explain
the fall off at the high frequency
the e to the minus h
bar omega over temperature basically
and um and this was a reason why you had
to
quantize electromagnetism was to prevent
that spectrum from just going out
unstably to infinity
and so we read that in several different
versions and i thought
i wonder if you can make gravity waves
do that
that is if you make gravity waves put
them in a box
and force them into a catastrophe which
you had to say
by saying they were gravitons and then
the age barrel may be
with the energy applied to gravity as
well to gravitational waves
as well and you know what you can't do
it
you can't make the analog of conducting
plays which
which reflect and keep
confined gravitational waves you can
show
and i manage i'm not that good at this
kind of stuff but i managed a
derivation of the um
efficiency of reflection of
gravitational waves
off a wall made out of any material
and as long as the speed of sound of
that material is less than the speed of
light
and the thing is not a black hole in the
energy the positivity of energy
conditions are met then you can show
that the efficiency
is bounded way way way away from one and
the gravitational wave just saunters
outside the box
never is forced to come to equilibrium
and you can even build on that and show
that in the history of the universe a
gravitational wave you'll never come to
equilibrium
that is um at any time
since the big bang in a big bang picture
the mean
free time of gravitational waves
is longer than the cosmic time and you
can show an inequality
like this so i think that's a little
there's an interesting bit of physics
that supports you
interesting and if you uh
if you look you know out at kind of
other tests that one could
you know devise it's natural to kind of
look at
um you know look look for tests that
could potentially be
crisp or decisive test as uh there's a
word for this this
uh in latin this you know critical tests
that that could not uh the theory could
not survive
otherwise uh but to pass this test the
bending of light by
massive objects the eddington experiment
is often cited as such an example
even though many experimentalists doubt
that it was really truly feasible in the
technology back in 1919 to truly
verify the level of precision that
einstein achieved but but nevertheless
we won't get into that people can read
your book
uh and and jim gates's books and other
books about einstein which
of which there are many but i want to
turn to the other aspect which
which kind of fascinates me and also
dismays me about uh about string theory
but about you know kind of all theories
of everything and
our mutual friend max tegmark uh has
written about these
and and that's really the multiverse uh
and
this is quite disturbing in some ways uh
especially not the least of which are
the you know the multi-multi-verses that
max speaks about you know the kind of
four levels of multiverses
that can exist including a multiverse in
which
uh you know the laws of nature can vary
from string vacuum to string vacuum and
this is part of the fight i had with
michio kaku
uh of course you know he was a gentleman
even if i wasn't uh but the but the
argument was you know
i said to him you know you say it's not
fair to test string theory
because i have to tell you uh which of
the 10 to the 500th or more vacua
we live in and and he said that's just
like solving newton's equations how many
solutions are there in a newton's
equation
i said there's an infinite number of
solutions to newton's equation how many
solutions to maxwell's equation there's
an
infinite number what do you need to
solve them he asked me i said boundary
conditions initial conditions
but i said the situation seems hopeless
in string theory
and even more hopeless maybe than max
tegmark would admit and i think i've
discovered a fifth level of the
multiverse lee if you'll indulge me
and forgive me because um as i think
rabbi used to say
the nobel prize should go to someone who
doesn't discover a new particle
back in the 30s but in this case i think
the nobel prize should go to someone who
doesn't discover a new multiverse
i'm worried that there could be a type
of multiverse where not only the laws of
physics change but the laws of
logic change in other words why should
it be that modus tollens
holds in some universe where or two plus
two equals four
in another universe and he claims no no
no that's that was a foolish question
but um but if if you know if there are
10 to the 500 different laws of physics
why should there not be 10 to the 500
different laws of mathematics
so of first of all of course there are
different
i don't know how many there are but
there are
different versions of set theory and
logic and mathematics
depending on how you answer
questions like the continuum hypothesis
and the exclusive middle and there's a
whole
bunch of different logics and different
worlds of mathematics and that i find
that fascinating
since i'm not a platonist i don't
believe i don't have to believe that
they're real
and any of them are real but you know
they're they're
they're structures by which we reason
and it's what you say is interesting and
what
i don't know if it's worrying but um
it's it's it's interesting i could come
back to that because
because i would think a lot about
mathematics and i'm worried about it
especially since i'm finally playing
this um
right
so um i do want to talk about this uh
this third paper that you wrote
um co author was stefan and six other
authors jaron lanier
jerome lenier can you say something
about him he is an interesting character
he's uh his his affiliation is listed as
microsoft research
in redmond washington i once met him in
berkeley california
can you say something about jerome i
know he's a friend of yours and stefan's
but he's an interesting character is he
not
he's a very interesting person and i
i feel very lucky to have him as a
friend and
very good friends um
jaren is speaking about autodidact
didactus jaron is almost entirely
self-educated
he went to a few schools a few times
he is um
wonderfully imaginative wonderfully
he's really um quick he's he's
a great communicator he's a great writer
he's one of the few people
i think of as you know this class of
people who are endlessly original and
have endlessly important things to say
and he does have a lot that's very
important to say
whether it's about thinking about
artificial intelligence or
the role in the economy of the internet
companies
and so and lots and lots of other things
besides we were talking with him
yesterday
about a whole lot of these things um
yeah yeah go ahead so here's how that
came came to be um
so first of all i have been interested
as we mentioned
the idea that the laws of physics could
change
for a long time and there was
cosmological natural selection which we
discussed
i had another approach i have another
approach called the principle of
precedence
and jaren is interested in that idea and
over
several maybe it's even many years
jaren and stefan are also friends and
they're both musicians
one thing jaren plays an incredible
variety of
musical instruments from all over the
world
um and there are so many stories to tell
that i'll skip doing that
now um well there's one
let me just bracket this this is the
time
jaren took stefan and i to meet ornette
courtney
and let me just use it can you uh speak
a little closer than microphone
there's the time that jaren took stefan
and i to meet lynette coleman
oh that's right which stands out in my
is one of the very fortunate
experiences i've had sharon
has jaren is among other things a
computer scientist
so we didn't even get to that he is
credited with inventing virtual reality
um he is and his position in microsoft
um i don't really understand it but it
seems to allow him
complete freedom to do whatever he wants
and think about whatever he wants but
he's also involved
too in projects there and
um so anyway um over
years he and stefan and i talked about a
variety of different ideas
and i don't know where the key idea in
the paper comes from i try to think of
it
the key idea in the paper is that
we can talk about the laws of nature
learning and learning the laws and
finding
the its way around those vacuums that
you're worried about
to one that is somehow benefits the
universe best
and this sounds crazy and
what we're going to argue is the
following
um there's a lot in that paper that's an
80 page paper about what learning is
because we had to do it because
we couldn't find it anymore but let me
skip that and say that
people are interested in these machine
learning algorithms
and let's just give me that
what they do is to learn they learn
facial recognition they learn pattern
recognition
they learn bunch of other things and
let's not get into the epistemology
of what it means to say that one of
those machines or algorithms learn
something
you just give it to me that they learn
and i'm going to take your favorite
candidate
for the laws of nature as long as
they're of the form of something like
general relativity and something like
gage fields and
fermions and scandals and we're going to
map
that theory into
the learning machines the machine
learning algorithms
and we discovered that now i don't i
don't remember
why we were looking for it but at some
point very clear that there was a man
and the map uses a technical result
which i knew which has to do with a
class of models called matrix models
and that's that's just the technicality
that was used
so we have demonstrated that result
and then we have
thought about what devices you could
make
that could be mapped to
the laws of nature
to investigate this idea there were
seven people on the paper everyone was
essential
and and they ranged from
a senior microsoft computer scientist
who knew
was kind of bringing in
all of the knowledge about machine
learning
will cunningham who's a very talented
young
theoretical physicists who unfortunately
would learn that you're losing
at the moment to the world of startups
and it was a lot of fun it was really
hard i haven't worked on
anything you work in collaborations all
the time
yeah and for me it was kind of a new
experience to work in a collaboration
that much
and it really did work and it came
together but it took a year that's a
full year
of meeting together three times a week
that's great and there's and you don't
know what's on the cutting room floor
there's a whole bunch of stuff on
yeah i believe it yeah so i'll try to
get geron and stefan on the podcast at
some point too stefan's been on three or
four times already but i've never met
i've never had geron on i'm going to
have nathan mirvaldon who was
director of research at microsoft for a
while and there's a kind of an
auto didact and maybe that'll um segue
to my final question
for this interview i hope you'll give us
uh the opportunity to talk more
about uh physics and in the intervening
you know month or so before we can talk
again about uh maybe cosmo
we'll do a dedicated cosmology talk next
time you'll probably write 10 other
papers
and three books but um but i do want to
talk uh just
just once about you are you know i see
you as an autodidact you've written
papers in
economics you've written papers in in as
you say set theory
and physics and cosmology you've written
six books
um to date um what uh and speaking of of
learning as we just did with you know
computer learning
um do you think you can teach creativity
lee can you teach someone to be
imaginative to be creative um is there a
is there is there a nature nurture thing
or
you just have to be born with it
that's a very good question and i don't
know
i certainly believed that
it was teachable most of my life
and i would i would hope that that's
true because it's
uh being created is a great thing and i
would
hope that everybody whatever however
their life was organized
had access to that has access and it
doesn't
mean that you're good at it i mean i'm
not good at
i'm not a good musician i got unlike
stefan who is a good musician
i got good enough to play with the
people who are really good and then it
was like okay
that's not that's not my genre but i
still have a few guitars and still play
them
sometimes um
and i've i'm working with
two people now that are unusual people
to be working with
and they're endlessly creative and smart
and i don't know where it comes from i
um you know jack
jaron stefan clelia
um so many people i've been fortunate
enough to know have this their own ideas
about everything
they they look at they look at the world
the same world i look at
they read the same stuff and they
come up with stuff just it's like
turning on a faucet
stuff is worth thinking about and worth
listening to
and um i don't know
i don't know where that comes from um
there are certainly claims that you
can't teach it
and um
but i'm gonna i'm gonna take a left turn
on you
um here's what i think is
changeable and uh and i hope i don't
sound like
i don't know when you feel moralistic
something
um and people are going to look like he
said
but let me try it i think character
matters
enormously and being in this crisis that
we've been
i see it every day and i think
that um
the ability to
see clearly what's going on around you
and take responsibility for it and think
about it
the ability to follow your own compass
to not care is fine and put it what
other people think
um i think
and um i have a
friend i've learned a lot from saint
claire cement who's this doctor he's a
great sculptor
and saying so i'm going to leave it with
the kind of quote of saint claire
um sinclair used to tell me
that um
that you get sort of into your 20s for
free
and if you're if you're going to go on
and become
useful and really make a contribution
with what you do
it really starts to matter what your
character is and
how much you're willing to be on the
edge
and take risks and
question yourself and
by 50 and 60
it really start it really shows it
really starts to show
he was probably 40 something and i'm
about 10 years younger than him
and then i'll say something else you
don't have to keep this in the tape or
not
no that's great but um this is i'm
saying this to you
from him anyway um unlike you
um we had
children late and
had to be and talked about it and
thought about it
and he had his daughter a few years
before
we had time and he said to me
you have no idea what you're
giving to the world by having a child
you're unmurdering somebody
and you're doing this to the much higher
degree than i am
but i am certainly fully involved
and it is a great thing to do you know
that's
it's wonderful that you say that lee and
actually i was going to close with this
to give us some time between our next uh
conversation
but i i did want to say that i once
heard you know sam harris talking about
you know the impossibility of
you know teleportation and you know time
travel it's kind of this this fantasy
that human beings have and i said no
that's that's actually a lie
i didn't say it to him because you know
he won't pick up the phone when i call
him but but anyway
um i said actually there is such a thing
as teleportation it just you can't
teleport yourself
you teleport your values you teleport
your ethics you teleport your character
into the future and it's called children
and it doesn't even have to be your
biological children lee
it's your ideological children and i
count myself and
and i don't blame you but i count myself
as kind of one of your
ideological children so you know i have
a great you know friend
uh you know her name is melanie notkin
she's known as the savvy auntie she
can't have chills she didn't have
children whatever
she has influenced thousands of millions
of people even though she didn't have
biological children so i'm blessed to
have biological children but even if
someone is not
you can act like a parent you can
communicate and thereby
doing teleport yourself into the future
and what else is there lee that's time
travel and and
and you've done that for me and you've
done that for millions of people i just
want to thank you so much lee
for being uh being such a great human
being and being an influence on me even
long before you knew me
and and again you don't get any of the
blame for anything bad i do with your
good
influence whoa brian that's uh
thank you i have no words thank you
well lee thank you so much for going
into the impossible
i hope you enjoyed this episode with
lise mullen if you did you'll definitely
want to check out this episode with lee
and eric weinstein you'll also want to
check out other theories of everything
including critics of string theory just
like lee
featuring sabine haasenfelder and carlo
vivelli click this playlist right here